welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and avengers in-game directors the
russo brothers revealed
a new reason that we gotta re-watch this
over three hour long film and no it's
not so that we can all get creeped out
by their nephew for looking directly
into the camera
in a recent reddit ama the russos were
asked are there any important easter
eggs in endgame that haven't been found
yet
and they responded of course yes period
and if you zoom and enhance on that
period you'll see that it actually says
not really we just want to drive eric
voss insane
well too late now look it is highly
unlikely that the russos have seen
every one of these obsessive breakdowns
of re-watches on every channel
in every reddit post these men are
professionals they're busy making new
amazing movies about black panthers
saving bridges yeah i assume that's what
21 bridges is about yeah so it's super
easy for the russos to just say
we did put a ton of crap in there and
who knows if everyone spotted everything
so if he gets those nerds buying
billions of blu-rays so that we can
dance
more on avatar's grave then sure happy
hunting
but even if this is bait i bit that hook
years ago i have already
rewatched this movie enough times to
form a whole new list of more easter
eggs that we miss the first times
like who i think is the true identity of
new master 69
ant-man secret crush loki sightings i
mean i don't know one of these
might be the important one that the
russo's hinted at so
let's comb back through adventures in
game scene by
scene for the really easy to miss
details and i am going to focus on the
new stuff like i
already covered this thing pretty
comprehensively in a two-part breakdown
back in april
and a more recent re-watch of the final
battle now that we have it in digital
a ton of other episodes on this channel
so yeah i've already found howard the
duck i know hulk's eating that special
ice cream i know there's all this kind
of stark death foreshadowing that music
with cap and peggy at the end's
important yeah i know but for the new
stuff here we go okay early in the film
when stark and nebula are stranded on
the benatar in the vastness of space
behind the ship
a number of moving objects are visible
among the stars
could they be debris from thanos spike
in that moon empty ghost ships after
their crews were snapped away
asteroids being sucked into galactus
mouth but they
are moving but then back on earth
screens show the snap victims
which also it turns out includes sharon
carter you might have spotted that one
already but the writers did say that
sharon was actually in earlier drafts of
this script
living with steve rogers going through
relationship problems which i presume
probably related to the fact that
steve's keeping a compass of her great
aunt
but sharon carter will play a role in
the upcoming falcon and winter soldier
series on disney plus then there's this
interesting exchange between stark and
rocket
honestly until this exact second i
thought you were build-a-bear maybe i am
now rocket probably doesn't know what a
build a bear is
but this is a nod to his mysterious
origin he is not a raccoon he was
built in a lab and james gunn has hinted
that guardians vol 3
will explore his origin carol danvers
also drops an interesting detail when
discussing alien healing technology
you guys take care of him and i'll bring
a missouri and elixir when i come back
so the zorians are from the marvel
comics
they were the rumored ancestors of all
the humanoid races in the universe
including humans cree skrulls it's
really just a convenient reason that all
of these races of aliens
happen to just all walk on two legs with
one difference being like
some are green and purple but zorians
coming up here could hint at an upcoming
exploration of these human origins
and things like the eternals maybe
guardians vol 3 or captain marvel 2.
a little later on there's this close-up
of cap's eye as he blasts into space for
the first time in his life
now the framing matches the shot of tony
stark in his first time outside of
earth's atmosphere in the first avengers
parallelism reflects how cap and stars
swap trajectories in endgame
stark finally makes the sacrifice play
cap finally arrives enlightens
self-interest
then five years later in the group
therapy scene on the wall is written
for god and country immemorial to
chaplain matthew haggerty matthew
haggerty was the name of the second
assistant director
for avengers infinity war and in-game as
far as we know he hasn't passed away or
anything but the second a.d
is typically one of the more thankless
positions on a movie set now he is
thanked
of course there are far more crew
shoutouts among the names of the golden
gate park memorial that scott
visits i scrolled through a lot of them
in my first breakdown a new one that i
spotted
dan deleo the movie's visual effects
supervisor now back in avengers hq black
widow holds that conference call i want
to revisit what okoye mentioned
net it's an earthquake under the ocean
we handle it by not handling it some
have suggested that this underwater
earthquake
could be a nod to namor coming into the
second black panther film it also could
be an odd to
thor's midgard serpent whom i brought up
in recent episodes
and many incarnations this giant serpent
lives under the ocean
and it was actually in the original
script for infinity war also rocket here
is wearing a red scarf now
this is the same scarf that peter quill
once wore in past guardians movies it's
rocket's way of paying tribute to his
old friend
when scott lang shows up he has an
interesting exchange with natasha
have either of you guys ever studied
quantum physics only to make
conversation his throwaway joke might
also be a nod to natasha's past
friendship with physicist bruce banner
with whom she likely spent many hours
keeping him calm with brainy small talk
and weird palm strokes jumping ahead a
bit to tony after morgan's
eye woofy thousand line comes downstairs
and tells pepper
not that it's a competition but she
loves me 3 000.
oh does she know you were somewhere
below 6 to 900 branch
yeah so tony's kind of making a 69 joke
here
but isn't there another mystery
character with this kind of sense of
humor in this movie for example
a certain notorious fortnight username
yeah
is tony stark nudemaster69 it's totally
plausible that stark would be spending
his idol hours trolling thor korg and
meek on fortnight he is
up late hours into the night which would
line up with new asgard's time zone
well yeah maybe i'm just reading into
that joke but notice what thor later
says when he's screaming at new master
oh that's right yes go cry to your
father little weasel and what does tony
do in this movie
um the guy has a super emotional reunion
with his old man
so yeah i guess i'm leaning more toward
new master 69 being deadpool
but we got a decent case here for tony
stark when the other avengers experiment
with time travel fun little detail here
banner hulk has to use a pencil to
operate the switches on the device
because his fingers are too big hulk
needs to lay off those sausages his
fingers are turning into him in new
asgard he might have spotted a big dude
lumbering around in the background now
some people said this could be beta ray
bill
it's not it's not a corbin knight from
what i can tell could be though some
other sakara gladiator might have ended
up with their group
also you'll notice among the beer kegs
in thor's supply
is one brew labeled asgardian ale now
there are some more interesting easter
eggs hidden in thor's home but
first thanks to our sponsors skillshare
for helping us make this episode
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes
covering dozens of creative and
entrepreneurial skills
explore classes and everything from
photography and creative writing to
marketing productivity and more its
premium membership gives you unlimited
access to high quality classes from
experts working in their fields
to help you gain new skills and live
your best life as a screenwriter and
filmmaker myself
i've been getting a lot out of iphone
videography shoot and edit video using
your iphone with cielo de la paz
i'm learning cinematography basics that
i can apply right now
no extra equipment needed skillshare is
also incredibly affordable especially
when compared to pricey in-person
classes and workshops an
annual subscription is less than ten
dollars a month and because skillshare
is sponsoring this episode you will
receive
a two-month free trial by clicking the
link in the description
just go to skl.sh newrockstars13
or click on the link in the description
okay back to thor's home
there are candy pez dispensers for hulk
and
iron man and on the bookshelf are titles
like small group decision making
much like thor has learned to do with
the avengers along with do it by jerry
rubin which was kind of like a
counter-cultural motivational book
on the back cover it reads do it is a
declaration of war between the
generations
calling on kids to leave their homes
burn down their schools
and create a new society upon the ashes
of the old so yeah you could see how
thor would embrace this idea as he
wallows in the ashes of ragnarok
still trying to move on from his parents
deaths on this post-apocalyptic earth
later when thor briefs the others about
the reality stone he puts in eye drops
but only in one of his eyes because yeah
his right eye is a prosthetic eye given
to him by rocket and infinity war
after hella popped it out in ragnarok
and staying with these story details
because i just love them so much
when the time heist begins and they
venture to asgard i can of the beer that
thor had been drinking has been left as
litter
so this means that thor brought a can of
beer with him shrunken down through the
quantum tunnel
back in time so that he'd have a roadie
amazing back in 2014
nebula gamora and thanos are conquering
a planet and in a shot of thanos ship
the planet's surface is ablaze and
explosions can be seen
each one blacks out the surrounding grid
and it looks as though
only half of the surrounding area is
getting blacked out each time maybe
reflecting thanos's quest to cull
half of each civilization that he meets
then back in time in new york after they
detain loki and loki pretends to be cap
when he switches back to loki hulk
suddenly tenses up
clenches his fists he's kind of like a
worked up dog that you play peekaboo
with and uh maybe it's just me here but
scott lang
does seem to be giving off some sexual
vibes and not just by saluting america's
ass
any of us would do that he says this to
tony i'm going inside you
and earlier he poses pretty suggestively
saying flick me why is he gonna stick
his butt out look i'm just saying
written out in a comic word bubble
the phrase flick me would be in all caps
italicized and look a lot like something
else yeah no apologies for dragging your
mind into the gutter with me now one
possible clue has come up with the date
that tony tolcap as the time
both the tesseract and spare pin
particles would be at camp lehigh in new
jersey zero four zero four
uh zero seven zero seven excuse me 970.
so this would place their second jump to
the specific date
of april 7th hey my birthday 1970
not my birth year now i guess you could
read this with the international month
and date order
which would be like july 4th 1970. i
think this would have to be before
tony's established date of birth
which was may 29th 1970. now later tony
asks his father howard how far along his
mother is
and tony seems just a bit surprised at
howard's answer
some have interpreted this to align with
a more recent reveal in the marvel
comics that tony stark was
adopted by howard and maria following a
previous baby
born with major health issues now i
don't know about that
i don't think endgame wants us to
conclude from this heartfelt stark
father-son reunion some
deeper conspiracy about tony's childhood
but we are left wondering whether tony
chose april 7 1970 in particular
like he knew some particular memory
about his father howard involving
sauerkraut and flowers
and being at the office too much or if
he just chose this date as being within
a certain window that both pin particles
in the tesseract would be at this place
based on i don't know reading his
father's old diaries in iron man 2. now
when cap sees peggy carter in the base
she and her lieutenant are discussing
something that apparently can only be
understood with subtitles
[Music]
yeah so they're talking about someone
named braddock being held up by
lightning
braddock is probably a nod to brian
braddock aka
captain britain a british version of
captain america who later is part of the
captain britain core
composed of alternate reality
equivalents of other marvel superheroes
perhaps
in the normal timeline before a cap went
back in time to rejoin peggy and start a
new timeline there was that mysterious
soldier that peggy carter ended up
marrying having kids with well maybe
that was brian braddock captain britain
which honestly would seem like a bit of
a step up for peggy carter
my yank cap turned himself into popsicle
so let's make me a new beefcake who
knows the words to gold save the queen
and as howard leaves with jarvis from
the base there is one dude sitting in
the background
pale skin long black hair could this be
loki we do know that he portaled away
from 2012 with the stolen space stone
branching off in a new alternate
timeline now the upcoming loki series on
disney plus
will explore the god of mischief
affecting events throughout the past
mcu human history there was even concept
art that showed him
on earth in the 1970s and look if we're
willing to call a random extra with a
hot topic skirt gwen stacy i just think
it's worth considering that camp lehigh
might have had another costume time
traveler hanging around after the time
heist hawkeye returns heartbroken over
natasha's
self-sacrifice and on his wrist he's now
wearing her widow's bite bracelet weapon
the filmmakers have also pointed out the
visual clue of evil nebula's hand it was
still
intact as she fiddles with a quantum
tunnel device to bring thanos to the
present but remember
the true present-day nebula's hand
burned up when she pulled the power
stone orb from the temple on morag then
after hulk snaps everyone back when
thanos's ship blasts the avengers
compound
scott lang very subtly shrinks the
moment of impact
showing how he was able to survive this
now this leads to the third act final
battle which i already rewatched in our
most recent breakdown
and be sure to check that out for some
cool details about what spider-man was
swinging from
a bunch of various mcu callbacks and
whether that is gwen stacy or not and
please stop tweeting me about
stormbreaker folks
yes only mjolnir requires worthiness
because of odin's charm
so thanos lifting stormbreaker in no way
makes him worthy that was already my
argument
got it thank you but a few more
interesting details i want to point out
when cap tightens the strap on his
shield can actually see how he did that
to form a tourniquet over an open gash
on his arm
also when all the fallen heroes return
to join the battle through portals
wasp hope vandyne arrives their own tiny
portal
and then sighs back up to normal after
flying through now one continuity error
i pointed out in the previous breakdown
showed giant scott lang
shoving a leviathan through a portal
which would be out of sequence
because at this moment he was actually
down to normal size with hope in the van
some are wondering though where that
leviathan would have gone
and whether it would have been spared by
stark's final snap and left to wreak
more havoc
wherever it was teleported to but it is
likely that wherever this leviathan went
it would have gotten dusted as well
since the filmmakers have suggested that
the stones operate in a kind of
wish-making sense so that when hulk
snapped people who were in airplanes at
the time of the earlier
dustin wouldn't die hulk could just wish
for everyone to return safely
just i guess not safe enough to avoid a
marching band nerd getting sidelined on
the basketball court and far from home
so yeah whatever stark wished probably
took up that leviathan wherever it went
but in the final dog pile
thor presses stormbreaker against thanos
and then he double summons mjolnir
to weigh down stormbreaker keeping it in
place
since thanos would be unable to lift
mule near and then another detail
revealed recently in a tracking shot at
tony stark's funeral
among the many cameos of this shot is
also apparently a little cameo for
marvel head kevin feige he isn't really
visible but he was sitting with the
producers in a video village
on the other side of the windows inside
stark's home and then one final visual
detail uncovered in this rewatch right
before cap goes back in time to return
the stones
many have spotted a helicopter carrying
a large crate in the far background
presumably this chopper was carrying
equipment for this new base camp that
hulk and cap had been operating from
like bringing scavenged parts from the
debris of avengers hq
so that they could rebuild a new quantum
tunnel for cap or
you know it's a weapon x chopper
carrying wolverine just pick the reality
you want to live in which of these new
details do you think could be the
missing easter egg that the russo's
mentioned do you think it exists at all
is the real endgame the game marvel is
playing with us to keep this goddamn
movie relevant until the end of time
comment down below with your thoughts
and follow me on twitter and instagram
at eavos and subscribe to new rockstars
for more breakdowns and theories about
everything marvel
thank you for joining me and if i
haven't found the damn easter egg yet
rooster brothers if you're watching
if you could just say one of the ones
that i mentioned was the right one
that would save me a lot of stress
please
[Music]
you